Rising costs squeezed households a
Sprinkle of higher interest rates
all the ingredients for a recession the
key metric for the UK economy gross
domestic product foul in the third
quarter not a surprise perhaps but
statistical confirmation that the
country is facing a tough economic
winter
this chocolate retailer one of many
seeing the telltale signs of a consumer
slowdown I think every small business
has been weathering a storm that doesn't
seem to finish so now we have interest
rate now we have you know obviously
customer demand is something really
really worrying the only way that we can
actually make it through Christmas is if
it's more people decide to actually buy
our product so it's not in that way at
the moment so if we if we raise our
prices maybe less people are going to
buy so we we want to keep it as an
affordable luxury the technical
definition of a recession is when GDP
growth the bars here drops into negative
territory two quarters in a row the
latest data show it fell in the third
quarter of this year and the bank of
England is among many forecasters
expecting further falls into next year
and maybe beyond the bank of England
says that we are likely to be in
recession this is disappointing but not
entirely unexpected news and what we
need to do now is to present a plan to
the country to tackle the root cause of
the issues we face
this small business just outside York
makes bespoke items for building
companies and the entertainment industry
they're struggling with similar
pressures if it was one single Factor
then you'd say okay I can maybe shop
around I can look for a better deal it's
across the board it's material costs are
going up transport costs are going up
so all our suppliers are putting up
their prices on top of the squeeze from
inflation and interest rates the
treasury is also poised to add to the
pain next week though there's some
question marks about how they'll justify
it you would concede that it is to some
extent a subjective thing whether
there's a black hole or not depends on
whether you want to follow particular
rules well there is some Choice over the
rules what are called the fiscal rules
that you choose to follow when we
produced a fiscal statement that didn't
show how we were going to bring our
debts down over the medium term the
markets reacted very badly you might
have detected a subtle dig there at his
predecessor quasi-quartang and frankly
there'll be more of that to come the
idea that this eye-watering black hole
is a consequence of the last slot now
some would say that's ridiculous some
would say that when you're in the teeth
of a recession cutting spending raising
taxes are the last thing you should be
doing the deficits eye watering the
chocolates are mouth-watering
the economy is now underwater and maybe
that way for a while at Conway Sky News